this episode of the honeydew is brought
to you by Hawthorne stamps calm and
expressvpn more on that later let's get
into the do the honeydew with Ryan
Sickler
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it studio night pants
I'm Ryan Sickler Ryan Sickler com Ryan
Sickler on all social media go over to
my website sign up for the email list
make sure you're subscribed to the
YouTube channel and we've got time codes
on there now if you want to jump the
stories all that good stuff make sure
you subscribe to the patreon show as
well called the honey dew with y'all
where I highlight the lowlights with
y'all if you think you have a story or
you somebody you know has a great story
you think should be told please submit
at honeydew podcast at gmail.com night
pass nation thank you we just got a lot
shorter with night shorts now go get
your new all-woman I guess Florida
Arizona you guys are hot it is summer so
go get your night shorts we got the
coffee mugs in there now originally
these were just a gift for my guests but
everybody started one one so they're up
there now charcoal hoodies you all
wanted a it's all it's all there go to
the merch store get your merch and if
you're looking for musical lessons you
guys know our record here at the Santa
Monica Music Center go to Santa Monica
music com use code honeydew and no waive
the registration fee and give you a free
lesson when you sign up for a package if
you're looking for online lessons right
now I'm telling you this is the spot to
be you can have kick-ass Los Angeles
musicians train you or your kids learn
learn a [ __ ] instrument with your
kids guys you're stuck at home what are
you gonna do but what we do here every
week is we highlight the lowlights these
are the stories behind the storytellers
and it is a pleasure to have this guest
returned I'm gonna say out of the gate I
didn't think it was gonna happen but
like his father he has returned ladies
and gentlemen Tony
what's up today here man thank you for
coming absolutely pleasure I say I tell
them all time you're your mum are are
moment about your dad is absolutely one
of my favorite it's like my steel it's
like my steel cage match one of my
favorites of all time
sometimes in this podcast world
everything just clicks for a little bit
and you got the best out of me on that
day this show I thank you it means
everything to get you for it to be you
is I'm telling you it to top my resume I
love I love that you love it cuz you get
it you're totally [ __ ] you've been
laughing about it ever since
oh my god so let's we'll get to that but
before we do plug whatever anything you
want what do you guys want well we're
trying to version a kill Tony right now
with a with a extremely limited audience
sitting outside it's a whole it's a
whole crazy Fiasco over at Cal Tony
how's the streaming part of that going
no that's still solid or it's pretty
solid yet I mean we're getting through
it you know we're having fun with it
just the stakes are so much lower on
that show cuz there's no live audience
for the for the the vibe of the feeling
and they understand it how good or bad
someone did on stage or you know there's
so many little Nikki nakki things about
stand-up comedy that we just don't you
know it's just a different show so have
you done any of the digital stand-up
shows no yeah no I can't bring myself to
do it I'm gonna offered it and I'm just
like it's such stand up for me already
is hard enough as it is to then throw in
people's Wi-Fi connection oh yeah you
know all these other layers I'm like
yeah I'm gonna wait a little right and
then they're dog starts barking fire
hydrant explodes in the background yeah
they're screaming everything goes nuts
but yeah but I have a new a patreon
project it's a roast master class where
I'm talking exclusively about the art of
roasting and perfect for teaching people
how to do it better and they get a bump
proud student bumper sticker and I'm a
diploma after six months and I just did
a a livestream I came straight from that
and we gave people homework
last week and we went over their jokes
today and it was so much fun who's we
who do you work with just my producer
gage but during the livestream everybody
submitted the jokes that I had them
write last week that I told them to
start on last week which was just broad
Quentin Tarantino jokes because that's
what we were talking about and and it
was so much fun I got to give them
little lessons unlike little things that
you know you know and that I know from
being in comedy but like okay with you
move that there if you cut that out you
don't need those are completely
different
exactly and you know one of the cool
things was that like is it went on I'm
like where where are more of your
submissions people and they're like oh
those are the only good ones I wrote I'm
like sending the bad ones because this
is the the blessing here is that you
don't know what's good and bad and sure
enough it kept getting like better and
better cuz it was the Dumber jokes right
that in Frank Castillo was with me the
winner of season two of roast battle and
we were dying man at some of these jokes
that were stupid it's just a roast
master class it's at patreon.com slash
Hinchcliffe and can you get that on your
website in everywhere yeah gal - Toni
Hinchcliffe Comi that's great that's how
long you've been doing that now a
pandemic bro pandemic project right
there the first thing that I did it
started off as a complete joke the first
thing that I did creatively other than
kill Tony when this thing started was I
made a parody video of a master class
because they kept popping up on my ear -
yeah between like Rogen episodes or
whatever in the background or whatever I
was doing I don't know I didn't know if
it was just my algorithm or whatever's
given me master classes but I'm like
these are so ridiculous that I'm gonna
write one a stupid one and make one and
so many people were like take my money
please I want this to be real and I'm
like what and then my book EDG saw the
post and they're like we want to be a
big part of this and I'm like that was
that that was a parody and I like yeah
well yeah I'm like I'll take that bet my
bookie Dottie
sure enough they did great they did and
and but what's crazy is that and I was
literally thinking it on the drive here
was because I was thinking about how
cool it was going over these joe other
people's jokes it was just a thing I
randomly did like all right we got
homework I'll check it on the next live
stream thing next week and it went so
well that it became this so at the end
of this I gave them more homework I said
imaginary roasts of Elon Musk we'll
check those next week so now we got them
working and we're figuring out you know
how to make these adjustments and people
get to see other people's mistakes or
what they did right it's just fun I love
roasting I love making fun of people so
it's easy for me to sit down for an hour
hour and a half a week and talk about it
that's it absolutely and I get to bring
fun guests on if people that I've worked
with for 10 years you know had Sarah
Tiana on last week hilarious she's
awesome she's reminding me of things
that I didn't even [ __ ] remember but
like yes she told me that she remembered
when I started becoming a Republican and
she reminded me of it I swear to God I
did not even remember but it was when it
was when she was in the room as far away
as I am from you when we got our first
paycheck from the first Comedy Central
show that we wrote on and when I say I
was broke at this point I mean [ __ ]
broke broke broke like I was only eating
basically granola bars and bananas from
the craft service yeah and and it had
taken forever for Viacom you know how
these weirdos are oh we get 90 day oh
you write that all right we're gonna
kill that chick it's gonna be another 90
yeah oh it's gonna be six months before
I get paid this billion-dollar company
with these guys eating nature's Harbor I
can't even look at those granola bars I
swear to god it's one of the only things
one of the only things that the thought
of it makes me [ __ ] sick to my
[ __ ] stomach in the nature's Valley
granola bars fade so many of them anyway
so we finally get these checks
we're like six seven weeks into the show
I mean I can't even believe it right and
then I open it and I'm expecting this
crazy paycheck right of all these weeks
and all this stuff and I'm like what the
hell is this and they're like taxes man
that's how the
tax that's how they take out the taxes
for projects like this and and Tiana
reminded me she goes you said this is
how Republicans are born and when she
said it I remember saying that and then
I realized that was the day that I went
from that that it began the meter of
farthest leftist liberal even fiscally
that you can be to literally like it
started going to where now I'm like you
know I almost almost like you know Mitch
McConnell well what's great about that
is that that's the type of stuff that
happens you get reminded of literally a
story from ten years ago that you don't
even remember and you look back at
yourself like wow that is wild that I
said that because it was the truth that
is and it's not like I'm some
congressman or anything like that but
certainly my perspective on money
started changing that day well I also
like the whole arsenal of being able to
roast because that's like you talk
sitting here and talking to a lot of
comedians who were bullied or outcast or
whatever the thing that made them
ingratiated into those groups was that
they were able to make everyone laugh
yeah even if they couldn't fight or they
were the nerd if they were busting balls
and making some I laugh you were welcome
that was your thing yeah I know if you
have that skill at a party or a family
for like that's a [ __ ] where you could
lay on somebody at a [ __ ] funeral
whatever and that's the thing they don't
remember what that person looked like in
the kabbala gap [ __ ] Tony said I
remember one time my brother like my
brother has two kids there within a few
days of each other but two years apart
so up until they were I don't know ten
eleven when they figured out hey we
don't want to do double birthdays we
want our own [ __ ] they just doubled up
on the birthdays and there was always a
million things that doing his
wife was Ryan you go get all the alcohol
at the store
Derek's gonna go work half-day when he
comes so he's gonna cut the grass and
she's got us put in this [ __ ] trellis
thing like it's a hundred degree we're
dying we finally sit on the [ __ ]
couch I mean our asses hit we crack a
beer and it's like 1:30 and people are
starting to show up you know and it's
little kids and their parents and stuff
and his wife goes what are you doing
there's people here they need to be
entertained and my brother just looks at
her goes that you shot a higher two [ __ ]
Wow and I dude I left so I still
remember I don't remember anything about
that goddamn birthday but I remember him
telling her you should have hired a
[ __ ] clown cuz I hate it I was
beautiful and she just shot both of us I
was like we'll get out though beautiful
that's the kind of [ __ ]
nicely easy economy of words short and
sweet you should have hired a [ __ ]
clam my brother's a natural with it he
went to uh his wife goes Ryan will you
please explain to your brother why this
comment that he made is offensive and I
guess she was your performer explaining
okay so she tells me a story about this
lady she knows that I don't know if she
was in an act something happened and she
had been out of action local theater for
a little over a year and this was her
big comeback her husband also is an
actor in a theatre and has had no
layoffs so they go to watch this this
production and when they get done my
brother meets them and lobby with his
wife and he says lazy yeah you were
alright you're alright but he's really
good and I just started dying laughs and
I'm like they're get is the worst
[ __ ] babies yeah yeah that's my mom
was Segura she came up to me goes you
are alright but he's really funny she's
the Gores
yeah my mom's favorite comedian I love
that [ __ ] I love the inappropriateness I
love the people with the literal like
what right yeah bad compliment but to be
able to [ __ ] do it intentionally and
just shut it down light a cigarette walk
away oh man it's the absolute best
so I tagged you in a post recently you
wanted me to ask you about this yeah I
want to fill you in on this cuz it's
pretty interesting so I started a
patreon also called the honeydew with
you all where I talked to you all out
there
and they submit their stories and I read
though and like you I love it I'm
sitting there reading like what the [ __ ]
so I vet him and I'm trying to get
people and balance it all out and this
kid hits me up now I didn't know at the
time he was a kid I assumed and I said
this in the episode I don't know why but
not telling me your age or anything I
assumed this was some dude probably in
his 40s or 50s it's happening to a lot
of comedians lately this whole I thought
you were a normal age so uh he gets on
the camera and I'm like dude how old are
you you know he's like I'm 19 I'm like
did this just happen he's like yeah I'm
like holy [ __ ] I'm assuming I'm gonna be
talking to a man in his 40s 50s put some
[ __ ] together figured it all out this is
a kid who's 19 and tells me that you
know he has what he thought was his
biological father I think stuck around
to about eight left
they had a stayed in touch for a little
while and then it sort of Peter off he
had a stepdad come in and that guy was a
good dude too but one day he's in he's
18 at their high school friends and they
all knew they all knew and kept it from
him this whole time Oh bang this group
of kids knows that it's very possible
that his father's not his father and not
only that his dad's not his dad their
friend's dad is his dad oh my god oh I
know do you know how they know well the
girl okay so he grew up with his mom and
another lady were super tight growing up
and so he grew up with that daughter
they were relatively the same a sort of
like that cousins kind of thing you know
and she knew and she didn't find out so
later I believe and then told her
boyfriend well her boyfriend was his
best friend and then one night they're
all drinking and somebody walks up to
him and basically goes look man I got
some [ __ ] to tell you go see Tony and
he's like now you go see Tony so he sent
him to his best friend his best friend's
like look the guy that you think is your
dad is probably not your dad and not
only is he not your
dad it's her dad this is your sister
he's like what so they take a DNA test
and sure enough it is theirs they're
half siblings but he knows about her
he's claimed her and now he's married
with a to a woman who has two kids of
her own they're in the car and they call
that the brother and sister call him and
they go hey you know that whole thing we
talked about where whatever I can sorry
cameras Rob was you know your son he's
like hmm he goes well we took a DNA
tested he is he's like alright I'm uh I
might to call you back and what they
didn't know is he was in the car with
his wife and the kid they all [ __ ]
heard that oh and the guy I lived at the
end of the street all through the end of
the street all through middle school in
high school and he said I used to watch
his pickup truck drive by the whole time
and I'm like that's that guy's my
[ __ ] dad oh my god lived in I mean in
the neighborhood could you imagine like
your situation is you saw I believe your
dad's truck going by your friend's house
could you imagine if that friend was
your brother now no that's wild and you
know what's crazy is that if they I
wonder if he ever would have found out
if a friend didn't leak it you know if a
friend didn't perhaps overstep a
boundary in a way and also yeah how did
the mom take this do you know about this
so that was probably hard on her it
wasn't he said because the daughter went
back to her mom and said look this [ __ ]
came out he's gonna ask questions he
knows so the mom gave his mom a heads up
like expected it's coming so she wasn't
blindsided okay so when he went to her
and said look I know who my real dad is
she's like yeah I know and it wasn't a
big deal for her because she knew he'd
found out but the best part was his like
his stepdad picked up up from college to
drive him to see his mom and he's like
look man I had some [ __ ] came out I know
who my real dad is and he knew this lady
told the dad he's telling the stepdad
right on his way that he found
summer break I have a my real daddy yeah
it's like yeah man I'm sorry I've I've
I've known to like what everybody's been
told not to tell you and I apologize and
he's like well how do I tell my mom that
guys like you're all your [ __ ] just
do step down not you're over stepdad
that is Valerius that [ __ ] is
unbelievable and it makes you wonder how
many how often is this really happen in
your neighborhood because if that friend
doesn't tell him he might never know and
I think I would have eventually probably
have been told the truth
maybe I'm sure eventually about my dad
but if I had not figured it out on my
own they would have just waited until
you did and by the time they wait that
long it almost makes you wonder I mean
if that guy if that kid was 18 it's like
me at this point why why tell him I told
him to like you know how much money you
saved that [ __ ] dude mm-hmm you're 18
hitting them up like hey I'm your kid
who are you well it's an interesting
thing from my experience I was always
like once I realized what was going on I
did the math on it and I'm like you know
I don't even want that much stuff I
don't want anything my mom probably
wanted some money of course but it's
like I would almost be like you know I
um probably wanted to be like mom don't
bother him for money like I'd rather
don't scare this guy away any more than
he already has
please don't leave go three miles away
yes my mom she loves such a crazy sense
of humor that she I can't even imagine
she house she is a [ __ ] cackler you
know it's who I get my wackadoodle hard
laugh from you yours probably too much
Germany much yeah mom yeah
that's where people like ayran yeah
exactly it doesn't just you don't just
laugh like that out of nowhere you you
live with somebody for awhile in which
you're like is that yeah yeah
the silent moments in between are the
ones that get me when they can't breathe
oh I'm so happy though because she
listened to it obviously but I'm pretty
sure my dad didn't get ahold of that
treated like it's a kid exactly he
actually just died he just closed his
restaurant for the first time in over
two decades because it's virus yeah that
said yeah not cuz he's retiring and well
he's saying it's cuz he's retiring but
it's like you know that's uh it's like a
guy with too much pride I think to say
that the virus hit home too hard I mean
they're just doing like takeouts or
whatever it's just not the same for a
fancy Italian rescue I can't remember
did you work for him after you've now it
all out now no in fact cuz we just sort
of stuck to the plan because I found out
I mean we get I'm sorry for people first
of all listen to Tony's first episode
how were you when you found out when you
put it together like ten eleven you know
we're young right right or right in
there somewhere between nine and eleven
okay I can't remember which one now but
I found out the exact age right as the
like pandemic started like mid March cuz
I was double-crossing stories with my
older sister who's obviously a half
sibling because I'm the only one that my
mom and dad had together and I was
figuring stuff out but yeah so I can't
even really remember now my might
psychologically damaged mine exactly
retrace the steps but were we just
talking I asked you if you ever worked
for him right so you know I knew but his
family didn't find out until his wife
saw you was like you're a dead ringer
for your dad I remember that I mean like
it goes right but randomly right you
were like catering or something like
right I was bartending
an afternoon a high school reunion like
a 30 or 40 year high school reunion and
I mean a ghost at the bar it's like that
scene in a Bronx Tale where there's the
one guy and you see him with the gun
yeah like nobody else sees they're all
partying she's just staring at me like
that
crazy crazy oh she was right oh yeah so
they'll actually know I didn't know what
she looked like I knew of her I knew it
was I knew at that time it was basically
my moms like arch-nemesis because that
lady at one point had the man you know
my mom was on the side and she was the
woman that got to live with him and not
even wake up in the same bed they all
slept in separate beds and all that it
was like Willy Wonka it was like the
opposite of Willy Wonka actually but you
know those old in the 80s those you know
Italian Catholic relationships you
didn't get divorced you just got
miserable yeah stayed really just
separate bedrooms and once the kids were
out you started taking other bedrooms
and sleeping on bunk beds or whatever it
took to stay away from one another so I
didn't know what she looked like
but to be honest with you I remember I
knew it was her ice Ilona you know what
I mean like a walking bomb like is this
gonna be is this [ __ ] I don't I
remember your being busy too but time
just stopping like you know bartending I
don't know if you've ever done it but
it's the art is what's next you're
thinking ahead it's almost really good
to like have that have that type of job
as a stand-up comedian because that's
obviously what we're sort of tracking
you're living in the moment you're doing
things in the moment right but you're
also like what's next again oh yeah it's
interesting which is probably why you're
good and at pool and you like pool
because you're always thinking shots
three or four shots ahead I'm not
thinking about this one here I'm
thinking where exactly right that's an
exactly perfect perfect use of that but
what's crazy is that I never worked for
my dad because that happened after I was
sort of out of Youngstown I just went
back for that bartending gig don't we
save money again I think
I was 19 or 20 it's all getting mixed up
now 22 I came what 22 I started yeah I
was like 20 years old bartending in
Youngstown that goes to show you what
Youngstown's uh but what's crazy is that
in high school I worked at the pizza
restaurant directly across and I mean
there's nothing else directly across but
my father's right now that glass you see
grayed out the glass and are you seeing
him pulling it out a lot pull in and out
it getting packed in there with my
family members from his side I mean just
packed oh the family was there all the
time right yes cuz they didn't know
right and then before I knew at that
point knew at that point for sure yeah I
had to offer jeez you know 10 11 12
years and you're sitting at a pizza
place working for them probably a
minimum wage yeah Pig looking across the
street where you could be working for
your dad at least a couple bucks more
now this kid when his dad owned the RET
owns a restaurant hired him only pays
him a dollar more right then I was like
all the money he saved yeah in [ __ ]
child support he at least kick you $2.00
after an hour Jesus Christ
and it was a shitty little I mean
delicious pizza by the turn to food for
feelings oh my god I do
i people are always surprised is brutal
you know you know I work with Rogan a
lot and I will out eat him 97% of the
time mr. Baer man or I'll [ __ ] eat
all my rib eye and some mac and cheese
and some mashed potatoes and a [ __ ]
salad and a soup I'm discussed and that
hug I never saw no one needs better than
whatever worms are living inside my
[ __ ] body but I do I eat like the
fattest fat man you've ever I'm like nah
I got a case of like the Joey chestnuts
or something like that that's me I just
[ __ ] plow it down but I do I eat like
a sad fat
and and they never came over to get
Pete's or anything like that alligator
that's like sacrilegious to my father I
see I even eats in his restaurant yeah
oh yeah though like some of the most
famous pizza in the city different pizza
though his pizzas real Italian super
authentic this pizza over here is
[ __ ] thick crust greasy yeah tosia by
the way is this too in a different type
of delicious way you know it's the
margarita with the ricotta yeah but this
[ __ ] pizza was like uh you don't even
know how to describe it you know there's
nothing in LA like it to where it's a
medium crust [ __ ] just real naughty
make me hungry hates I know I know
but yeah that's uptown pizza and
Youngstown oh and would you tell your
friends that work there like that's my
dad over there and that's his place or
did you just shut up about ya know it
was sort of a known thing amongst my
people
he has never barrack and water-balloon
the place or launched we use netting
slingshots and launched him across the
street at places we didn't like yeah
water boy yeah and we would do that but
not at my dad's restaurant I always I
always still I thought he was cool as
hell he is cool as hell he's a cool dude
and you know I own every to like get
revenge or be mad at him it was always
like I said about the money thing it was
always the opposite like it's like I
always wanted him to think I was cool
too all I ever wanted was my dad to
think I'm cool that's it my mother used
to try to like once in a while she send
like $20 for Christmas or something I
would just tear it up and throw it in
the trash I don't also I never wanted
what the money what came with the money
I never wanted that you know what I mean
I knew it was gonna be some like well I
sent you $20 I'm like that so so what
you know so I I'm with you money and
money would it made me feel any better
exactly what it made me feel any [ __ ]
better right you're just gonna buy
something stupid anyway but but yeah so
how's your relationship now you
good relationship it's actually really
cool is it getting better or is it in a
great spot or or comfortable spot at
least it's in a great spot I don't think
it could be any better I don't think it
could be any cooler in fact I think as
the years have gone on I may have slowly
but surely become out of nowhere the
dark horse in a long horse race I think
I became his favorite Crazy Horse race I
think I ended up beating the kids that
were raised in his house
they probably drive nuts more ya know I
mean like I'm hearing his voice a little
bit you know I mean obviously because we
were basically only talking on the phone
but over the years I think especially
the comedy thing obviously it really
helped like 13 you know it's been 13
years 13 years ago the the annual update
or you know twice a year update it's
weird cuz we really only talk twice a
year which is on my birthday and
Father's Day he calls me on my birthday
I call him on Father's Day now the sad
thing about that and I've never really
even this is another exclusive to you
right here right now what's really sad
about only talking to your dad on those
two days is that my birthday is on June
8th and Father's Day is like the next
night after yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
so we but we a we made we like it's not
it and it's not even anything we like
outgoing ly talked about it yes always
how it works something like so it's
still like a year in between us talking
most of the time let's take a quick
break and tell you about our first
sponsor Hawthorn so I don't know about
you guys whether you wear deodorant
cologne whatever I was never a big
cologne guide always try like obsession
or whatever back in the day you know
polo high school all that stuff and then
just never really I never did it right
it was always too powerful you know I'm
on my they're rocking that cardigan all
that stuff and now with Hawthorne man
they sent me so many great men's
products the Cologne is fantastic I I
wish I got to use more of it my stepson
attacked it took both bottles I haven't
seen it at all now so he's keeping it
loves it doesn't want to give it back
but it does even his mom was like man
you smell good what is that he's like
that's Ryan's Hawthorne Cologne so you
got to give Hawthorne a try alright
there's a quiz they have a great quiz
where you can go through and they'll ask
you questions about your health care
your hair care your skin care all that
stuff and you can answer it and then
they'll tailor everything to you the
packaging is fantastic there are quality
products there's stuff that even did
look good on the counter you know
talking about they look good on the
counter the deodorant the shampoo the
body wash face cleanser lotion all that
stuff so here's how it works you take a
quick two-minute quiz and hawthorn will
tell you the two clones that are best
for you one for work and one for play
all right it's totally risk-free with
free shipping and free returns okay and
ladies if you're looking for Cologne or
something for your man you can get him
this stuff all right it's great you know
have to keep using guys on to keep using
your ladies high-end hair stuff you can
get your own stuff now so go to your
gonna check out Hawthorne at Hawthorne
dot Co I am saying that correctly okay
that's Hall form with an e at the end
and you're gonna use my promo code
honeydew you're gonna get 10% off your
first purchase
that's Hawthorne H a wth ORN e dot co
and use my code honeydew you'll get 10%
off your purchase Hawthorne dot CEO our
next sponsor is stamps.com and as we
slowly adjust to a new normal we still
need to be smart about how we're doing
business so luckily their stance calm to
make things easier thousands of small
business owners have discovered the
benefits of stamps calm in recent months
they've been able to keep their
businesses running and avoid crowds at
the post office all from their own
computers with stamps calm you can print
postage on demand and avoid going to the
post office and you'll save money with
discounted rates that you can't even get
at the post office and stamps calm also
offers UPS services shoutout to UPS
baltimore hub primary one joe avenue and
you get discounts up to 62 percent and
no residential surcharges alright
stamps.com brings all the mailing and
shipping services you need right to your
computer in the comfort of your home or
office so whether you're a small
business an online seller or you're just
working from home and need to mail stuff
stamps.com can handle it all with ease
alright you just use your computer you
can print the postage 24/7 for any
letter any package any class of mail
anywhere you want to send once your mail
is ready you leave it with your carrier
you schedule a pickup drop it off
whatever boom is that simple and like I
said with stamps comm you get great
discounts - five cents off every Stampin
Up the sixty-two percent off USPS and
UPS shipping rates it's a no-brainer
saving you time and money so right now
my listeners get a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus free
postage and a digital scale without any
long-term commitment all right you go to
stamps com you click on the microphone
at the top of the home page type in
honey-do at stamps calm and to code
honeydew our next sponsor is expressvpn
right so we all know right now how
expressvpn protects your privacy and
your security online right but here's
something you might not know you can
also use Express VPN to unlock movies
and shows that are only available in
other countries now that so many of us
are stuck at home it's only a matter of
time until you run out of stuff to watch
on Netflix so this whole week I've been
in using expressvpn to binge
dr. who on UK Netflix it's simple you
just fire up the expressvpn app you
change your location to the UK Yuri
flesh reflash refresh Netflix and that's
it
the expressvpn hide your IP address lets
you control where you want sites to
think you're located alright so you can
choose from almost 100 different
countries so just think about all the
Netflix libraries you can go through but
it's not just Netflix expressvpn works
with any streaming service hulu BBC
iPlayer YouTube you name it there are
hundreds of VPNs out there but the
reason I use Express VPN is because it's
also compatible with all your devices
your phones your media consoles your
Smart TVs so you can watch what you want
on a personal device or on the big
screen wherever you are if you visit my
special link right now at expressvpn
dot-com / honey-do you can get an extra
three months of expressvpn for free
three months a long time support the
show watch what you want protect
yourself with expressvpn at expressvpn
comm / honey-do now let's get back to
the do other than those two talks for
the last quite few years I go and visit
every December for like a night like
once uh so go to visit your mom but
you'll go over there right so like this
this past one when was I in here when
was I with you last step before December
of this year yeah I think it was because
I started this in March well video March
of last year you had to be in last year
yeah so like this and I'll always go eat
at his restaurant you know sometimes
I'll sometimes I'll be there with you
know friends or family you know I've
taken the wife in there I've taken past
girlfriends in there and this last one
the we were in the middle of a kill Tony
stretch of the tour so I had red band
Jeremiah and Joel this when you got
pulled over by the cops with your socks
on yeah so yeah we did Columbus and then
hits Bergen in Cleveland and
I had my agent strategically put a night
off in between one of those things
Pittsburgh and Cleveland which is right
where Youngstown is and I took them to
my father's restaurant and their minds
were completely blown I mean they got to
hear real Italian stories from a read a
had no idea I don't think anybody could
ever possibly guess how Italian my
father actually is because I talk like a
normal white guy from Northeast Ohio and
my father is so I mean he's literally
like Tony Soprano a hundred percent
maybe a little more Marco Marcos
Hinchcliffe your mom's then Hinchcliffe
is my mom's previous husband's last name
all my older brothers and sisters are
hinge claps okay so you all have the
Hinchcliffe yeah God and they got to
here real like and I mean he was he was
you know he had he had a lot of fun in
his days it's you know a pretty don't
know how to say this exactly right but
it's pretty you know Sopranos esque
Goodfellas asked that whole lifestyle
there in Youngstown and they got to hear
stories that like there were times where
Jeremiah's I was catching I'm sitting at
the restaurant there across the bar
telling us some of these stories my
father and his wife about him you know
over the years all the stuff that he's
done cuz I just kept going tell us
another one tell us another one and like
for example there was one where he's
like and where his his lady is like tell
him about Joey slaps and we're literally
like oh yeah you got a dude was about
Joey slaps and he's like they don't
wanna he's like you told him about Joey
slaps you'll be able to tell them better
than and so she goes into it you know
they used to stay open till 4:00 a.m.
and he would always take me
whatever is going on and oh he was
trying to get one of his buddies out of
the bar because the cocaine dealer guy
was going to try to sell that guy
cocaine and he was trying to get his
buddy off cocaine my dad was never into
any drugs but he's trying to help his
buddy out because he sees it's the end
of the night and this cocaine dealer
walked in and he knows that he's there
to sell his buddy cocaine so he's like
come on we're all getting out of here
and he takes his buddy and the cocaine
dealers like what's going on
what the what are you doing why why you
leaving he's like get the [ __ ] outta ya
you know and this is you know now my
dad's telling the story I'll just say
how long for he's like yeah I got
exactly he gives her all this setup he
it's all the [ __ ] jobs literally and
and you know the cocaine dealers like
what are you dong come on I want to hang
out with your friend he's like we're
getting outta here you better get the
[ __ ] out of here and then um and then
the guy's like Oh what are you gonna
what are you gonna do big tough big
tough you know when he says his name
what are you gonna do pull your gun out
and shoot me or something and he goes no
I'm not gonna pull my [ __ ] well he
said that's when she takes over this
story again he hit him so [ __ ] hard
everybody called him Joey slaps for six
years after that that's why they
alley-oop the story like this triangle
she starts she brings the ball down the
court ball movement to him down at the
post and she's wide open at the end
Joey slaps for six years that's the part
where I remember Jeremiah who's a good
guy Jeremiah Watkins is like you know
he'll do a lot of crazy jokes it's all
in characters yes Jesus a good Christian
yes he is a very good Christian I'll
never forget his face because I'm
sitting there at the bar and they're
talking us in his face going like this
to me I thought look where they don't
leave their eyes
[Applause]
and I've been everywhere with Jeremiah
all around the world we've been done
places multiple times you know the bond
from that but you never forget moments
like that where they're finding out the
year father is like you know just beyond
the character I mean way beyond the
character I can't believe that in it's
cool as hell for me to think that my dad
is that cool has these stories like have
you ever had him on would you ever do a
zoom with them do you not want to like I
don't think you think he do you think
he's I just don't I think we probably
never leave you alone right no I mean
I'll tell you this is once we got the
momentum going to his stories I couldn't
believe that he had more like it I mean
show he slaps was just one with what it
was already although I'm just one of the
shorter stories either I loved that they
call Joey slaps because usually you earn
a nickname because you slap somebody and
you're Joey slaps he got that nickname
because your dad slapped the [ __ ] out of
him dude that makes me laugh so hard
everywhere you gotta go you gotta be
remind cuz there were other witnesses
here they said that it sounded like
someone took two pieces of wood that's
what they said like he was a legend for
a while Joey slacks i watch those slap
fights a lot you watch those where the
guys are at the table
hold on and what's funny is that when
she goes I just I just remembered this
right now is when she got him six years
Joey slept he goes I barely touched a
little a little whap and that's another
thing is you can't even aspect you know
around comedy all the time we're blessed
to get to hear all these jokes you get
to hang out with the Tim Dylan who
somehow is brain man [ __ ] man Dave
Attell these people were it's just it's
not that they're on it's not they're
just hilarious but then there's
something about that you just the
ultimate trump card is just a natural
person and their natural cadence and
they know they're [ __ ] funny and they
also knew that they were both funny
together my father and his wife they
both are like aware that there's four
comedians
Tony's [ __ ] love in this [ __ ] he's
dying drinking red wine after they just
fed us you know but he's also a [ __ ]
ridiculously unbelievable chef oh so we
just ate [ __ ] every thief everything
I know everything but unbelievable ever
the way it ended every time you do that
I keep picturing my mom's laugh watching
this episode for you
which is named Joey as for you joy
there's gonna be parts where she pauses
this [ __ ] and literally rolls around the
living room and then will crawl back to
the [ __ ] computer and laugh more well
it's got to be a thrill for them to like
you know those people you see them at
the small town restaurant the corner bar
whatever and they're just there they're
having their moment for them to light up
for comedians like that oh god they
probably never wanted it to end
yeah probably having the best [ __ ]
time they were they were and I I kept
asking for more like you know dangerous
stories I do remember any other ones
yeah I remember summer there's a couple
that I can't talk a couple involved you
know the the maybe maybe someone I don't
know maybe someone got hit with the with
like butt end of a pistol you know
little stories like that the little bit
not bedtime not bedtime stories you know
what I mean but you know it's rough it
was rough happenings where I grew up and
did he ever get robbed or anything like
that at the restaurant
they does not [ __ ] with him god no oh
good lord no nobody could ever police
never read it or no no he's very very
respected from everybody I mean he's
like you know he was the Italian fest
Man of the Year even the news last week
when they when he closed like it was it
was news everywhere all the channels so
yeah not even they're not even able to
stay open with delivery or and it's also
like that's all the one place and I and
I post mates a lot a lot of like way too
much but it's one of those places where
the food's so good that like delivery
from there ruin it yeah exactly it's
just not the same [ __ ] noodles you
can't even there's just no it's not
normal it's it's way beyond and he's a
complete perfectionist or else he
wouldn't even have been this chef at his
own restaurant you know and I can't
remember did your mom ever remarry or
yeah yeah and you get along with him
yeah he's cool yeah he's fun yeah he's
more of a just a normal guy you know and
they which is shocking to me that my mom
could sort of do that but I don't know
he must have like a big wiener has your
dad ever come to see you with Rogan or
anything like that you show on that
scale what's funny is that he I told him
when we when I found out that I'm doing
Madison Square Garden whoo yeah we Rogen
and Diaz well we're scheduled for it we
found out in December holy or October of
this year and well Congrats whenever it
happens well hopefully it happens or
else my dad's gonna be off the hook for
another [ __ ] live event that he
didn't have to come to during my entire
life he's like come on cuz when are you
going dad I went first ah we got here I
guarantee some [ __ ] like that'll
happen you know we must we missed the
but that guy was hilarious this guy is
great he'll probably love Diaz they
probably have a lot of similar
Dory's that's that is it dia if you
combine Diaz and Sebastian Maniscalco
that's your dad Tony Soprano you sure
that monster picture that picture that
monster Diaz and Sebastian but looks
exactly like Chas palm and Terry and his
basically has the Tony Soprano lifestyle
if he also ran that Vesuvio restaurant
and cooked in it yeah that was in The
Sopranos that's literally my father
crazy crazy
but wild in true well I love that you're
you've reconnected so twice a year you
talk you go see it while now you don't
even have the restaurant to go to if you
don't have anymore
yeah that's gone and I taught and I
asked him last week because it was we
just went through it or two weeks ago
what is it yeah few weeks ago talk to
him on Father's Day about it actually no
we had a third phone call because of
that yeah because of the restaurant
still hey all right talk to you 50 weeks
but I'd I'm like hey we gotta you know
we're dead it took me a while cuz like I
was you know compressing this
information of the restaurant being
closed which you know I've just been
staring at from even across whatever 15
good god oh oh my god yeah almost two
decades ago yeah no yeah I've been
looking at it for over two decades yeah
many many way over two decades in fact
anyway and it was just so much that I'm
like it and it was towards the end of
the phone call where I'm like yeah we
got to do something now I mean like I
got to eat your food yes crazy it's
crazy to think that wouldn't be able to
do that again but then of course I'm
like oh yeah of course there's other
kitchens he still has his technique but
I what's interesting about that is I
have never had a meal made for from him
at a home only at the rest
okay so it actually took my I'm actually
realizing this now like I'm like it was
at the end of in your life how old right
36 and you haven't had one meal prepared
in a home by him only at his rug nope
state of the art I mean not state of the
art but top of the top-of-the-line chef
Wow
yeah so when you go back now it'll
probably have to be a dinner at his home
yeah but do you think that'll be just as
good or or better will probably be
better I think so yeah I think so too
as a bill he'll make sure everything
will be even probably even more fresh
and have you been to that home have you
ever been in his home no no come on
never no never so hold on yeah all this
time went from reconnecting and even
when he yeah so when he would visit you
would he would only come to your mom's
do the whole gift at the door yeah mom
would do make him look like a hero
yeah joy you're a saint yeah yes she is
all of that was him coming your way and
then when you reconnected and you would
go his way it was only to the restaurant
exactly so the only granted he was
barely ever at home during this time I
mean he's that that restaurant yep four
am making the dough to you know to
[ __ ] midnight 1:00 a.m. drinkin with
the I mean he's not really a drinker but
he would have a soda or whatever or wine
well the drinkers are closing up the bar
you know those are the bars connected to
the restaurant and like you know and he
was just the neverending host that's
just how he operated is this the same
house that you spotted from the bus I'm
pretty sure you know same house yeah
you've been injured what's that gonna
feel like going in there that's gonna be
weird is your buddy or his parents still
live across the way that's a good
question
you gotta be knocking on all these doors
yeah good question but yeah I think so
that will be wild I never even thought
of that this is me thinking of this
stuff for the very first time wild to
think that I would get to go in that
same house that like I remember exactly
what it looks like to used to be when
you see that house in your mind
do you see it from the moment you put it
together and realize it or do you see it
for what it is now like whenever you
think back right now
oh yeah no you see it from the ten
eleven school bus yeah bus windows you
have to press that is brutal
Wow they get the guy I had a friend of
mine I reconnected with my mom after
like 30 years which is just a couple
years ago and a friend of mine said so
after my father died we were 16 we had
to we had to go move in with her the
state would give her a check as we were
all minors and rarely did she stay but
there were times she certainly stayed
there so my friend said to me how long
has it been since you slept under the
same roof as your mom and I was like and
it was one of those things where I had
to like take a step back for a second
like holy [ __ ] it's a great question and
it had been since 18 I was like it's I
don't know 25 20-some years since I've
slept under the same roof as that person
it's [ __ ] trippy to think that [ __ ]
yeah it's crazy I've never in my entire
life ever slept under the same roof as
my father never no not once
I'm not even an emergency or we'd taken
naps together when I was a tiny little
boy like he would come and you know fall
asleep after eating spaghetti but he
would leave you know what I mean it
wasn't a nighttime thing it's always
daytime and like there's pictures of me
crashed out on his chest it's a little
baby and stuff but no never no did you
just realize that right now I never even
really yeah that's all well yeah never
really thought about it all this stuff
is really it's interesting how our
brains protect us you know it reminds me
of being in Houston again you know
working work in that comedy club just a
couple weeks ago with Rogan it was it
was 30 45 seconds into the first
we had four shows two on Friday two on
Saturday and 40 seconds and I realized
like oh my god
this is so much more fun than I even
remember it and we stand up ya know yeah
and I feel like our brain protects us
sometimes like oh yeah that's your
favorite thing but it's cool yeah you're
good it's great it's fine but it's like
I mean getting that rush it during the
pandemic I think it really like I
haven't done stand-up since whatever
more I said one of my last shows it's
probably at the store it's more fun than
you remember early-to-mid Moore and I
point yeah like because sometimes our
brains I feel like protect us it's just
simple psychology so no I haven't
thought about never sleeping under the
same roof as my father or never being in
his house never really thought all right
so here's a question then you go over to
his home for your first time ever you
walk through that door you sit down you
have a wonderful meal do you go to your
mom's or do you stay over and sleep
there that's to break the cycle you know
what I like that idea
just to see what it's like yeah just to
see what it's like maybe to maybe try to
wake him up scare him in the middle of
the night see how hard he actually slaps
after all find out that there's any
truth to the story all right so I have
more questions yeah you and your wife
your personal business do you do you
want to have kids at some point are you
is it one of those if it happens it
happens or are you good the way you are
I'm good the way I am right now as my
question was gonna be do you think he'd
be a good grandfather cuz I yes or no I
mean he prizes he a grandfather yet with
any other kids I don't know I don't know
so no I mean I think he'd be good when
the baby's right in front of him yeah if
you if you put it right in front of them
they'd be great I know that for a fact
in fact my mom has reminded me that he's
notoriously even with me
he was really good when I was a baby as
a little kid yeah he's one of those guys
where it's like once they start growing
up and start like forming sentences yeah
exactly it's like all right it's too
much getting weird not asking questions
asked
[ __ ] now too many questions what
surrounded spelling who the [ __ ] you
asking all these questions for but yeah
and and I think that is a thing like it
it did get I could see why he would
freak out a little bit about that I
could see why because he's a great guy
we all were all good people but it
starts to get weird I feel like once you
realize like I'm not gonna be the father
that I should be so why would I want to
torture myself by being around that a
lot like I could sort of see as I get
older what his mentality was so what
kind of father is he to his biological
while you are alive I mean to his the
kids he had with his is it the same lady
he's still married to that lady right
now no differently yeah so how many more
kids is he has your sister has two kids
so three two original wife that found me
at her high school reunion
oh that's the okay got it and even
though they were separated at that time
and I mean divorced uh at that period of
time she was demanding that I need his
family because she was very close with
his family and okay the two kids and the
sister was excited to meet me but the
brother wasn't and that's what's
interesting is that they not the sister
but the brother I think has some some
real issue with the whole thing and I'm
not exactly sure why but I think part of
it is my dad was missing from some of
their things sometimes to come and join
me so I think they would go why why does
dad have to leave during Christmas for
two hours every year cuz he would write
yeah that's the whole pack especially
when I was a kid and again they're a
little bit older than me so he would do
that when I was 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
right in there right and at that point
they're 11 12 13 14 15 16
17 like aware and noticing like that no
don't go or whatever plus they had to
deal with him being a workaholic so I
think that they have especially the boy
has a bit of a pent up I don't know it's
interesting still I get the feeling he
does and are you closer with your sister
I'm close with my four older brothers
and sisters you know from your mom right
got it who say that my father was a
better father to them than their father
that's where things get really tricky
about is my mom and my dad I'm sure I
mentioned this on the last show but they
cheated on each other significant others
for 11 years right so during that 11
years he was hanging out at my place at
my mom's place a lot and this is before
you're even around right this is
starting 11 years before I'm born but my
older brothers and sisters however how
old's the oldest sibling like 20 years
older so it's well years older than me
is the closest one and after he was born
that's when my mom like my my their
dad's drinking or whatever was so out of
control that my mom like completely fell
out of love with him or whatever it was
but so it's 12 14 16 and 18 years Sam
they are they're older than me
oh wait 12 14 16 18 yeah something like
that or maybe there's another two-year
gap in there between one of them anyway
because my oldest sister is 20 years
older than me so I think it's 12 14 16
20 something like that anyway so for 11
years before I was born
they had him I so you know God no but
yeah right so he really like was there
for them Allah oh wow
so your dad was more of a dad to your
other yeah your brothers and sisters
that you yeah yeah
this is the [ __ ] we laugh about holy
[ __ ] I just was with my brothers on the
fourth of July and we laughed about it
again comes up all the time yeah he's a
great guy great guy to me sad that his
restaurants closing that guy was like a
father to me it's not a shame he wasn't
around for you it's a shame restaurants
I'm telling you I think this happens
more than we don't like that kid the 19
year old he's a fan of your show he
listens to it right I couldn't believe
it
and did I come up during that as he
listened to the Tony - I think I said to
him that's a tone like a Tony
Hinchcliffe or something and I tagged
you in that host via tube is I just his
mind is gonna be blown it is not all of
this and his dad owns a restaurants like
the same type [ __ ] see his stories also
his stories sort of a tricky one too
because it makes me wonder how he felt
about his friends after that
cuz it's sort of like I asked ya I was
like is it weird do you look at that he
said I've never had animosity I've never
I go but you're literally the last one
to know that feeling itself yeah it's
just a weird feeling regardless of who
the people were that knew and he said it
wasn't that weird because he was already
super close with them and he's like well
[ __ ] our brother and sister it's even
better so he's got a very nice boy he's
also only 19 yeah you know some travels
go ahead of it as twenties but right now
first drink trust any man I didn't know
that part so they knew him forgot 11
years I mean that's a long time to have
this dude come around and be a nice guy
yeah there's nothing like your brother
telling you your father taught me how to
tie my
but what but with that said what's sort
of cool is that I'm just grateful
everything happened the way that it did
even though of course anybody would say
that but like it was really cool getting
to have four older brothers and sisters
that age gap for so many reasons but
like I got to learn everything from them
you know I learned how to tie a tie when
I was frickin six or whatever cuz I
asked my you know maybe younger or
whatever but you know they're all
growing up and doing things and and I
got to go visit Ohio State University as
a child I mean way way beyond you know I
get to ride my bicycle around Ohio
State's campus for a month out of every
year because I would just go down there
and visit my brothers and sisters who
were all going there and you know I have
all these cool memories from getting
raised by older brothers and sisters as
well for a month out of every year to
get my mom a break and so it's cool some
to mama is five kids yeah that's a lot
of [ __ ] kids damn yeah your mom's
vagina must be gigantic good thing she's
got that huge we nerd husband you fit
her ready
that's what you need when you got a big
wiener
[Laughter]
so do your brothers and sisters they all
still live in Ohio like now no they're
all well the two sisters live in Ohio
and both brothers live at the beach out
here now one and all this one in here in
Santa Monica you see him yeah okay good
yeah we've been hanging out a lot the
pandemics been great for family bonding
July 4th we all hung out yeah it's been
like sort of like bi-weekly just random
barbecues on the rooftop out there in
Venice Beach beautiful sunburned like
hell yeah you look good dude you're the
man I mean I love that I'm asking
questions that are making you think
about [ __ ] like that so now you got to
go home for whenever you can and have
dinner in the house yes
you could break two in one night right
yeah dinner and sleepover yeah you gotta
come back for a part 3 when it happened
I cannot wait there will be constant
updates I can't wait anything changes
you will know you'll be the first to
know thank you I'll make sure of it
promote whatever you want again please
kill Tony still happenin and eventually
you know we'll be back out on the road
doing stand-up and everything and yeah
the new patreon project the roastmaster
class where we exclusively talked about
making fun of people and each other and
teach you how to do it better learn it
and study old film and new film and
roast battles and roasts and everything
so it's a lot of fun that's a
patreon.com slash inch clip it it you
can find everything at Tony Hinchcliffe
com including the brand new merch store
yeah at your hinge cliff red band 2020
t-shirt there it is go vote y'all thank
you brother thank you for coming on so
much this is always incredible anytime I
love hanging with you and everything
always but to know how hard these
podcasts make my mom laugh it's almost
like it's almost like a I look at it
like a direct zoom for her and
everything else is just lateral damage
that's great thank you man you're
hilarious thank you dude please sign up
for the YouTube channel sign up for the
patreon the honey do with you all and
Ryan Sickler on all social media Ryan
Sickler calm we'll talk to you all next
week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]